good afternoon good afternoon good
afternoon and welcome to the Chubb
fellowship lecture with our
distinguished guests faith Ringgold
award-winning artist author educator and
activist today's program is generously
supported by many units across Yale
University's campus we wish to thank
african-american studies American
Studies ethnicity race and migration
history of art women and gender and
sexuality studies the afro-american
cultural center Center for the Study of
race indigeneity and transnational
migration the school of art and we
especially wish to thank the Yale
University art gallery for hosting
today's lecture in this beautiful
auditorium so thank you you egg before
we begin I ask that you turn off all
cell phones and refrain from taking any
photographs during the program so that
you do not disrupt today's program and
once we get started the lights will be
fully dimmed so just be careful of your
surroundings when you because the lights
will be off my name by the way is Mary
Lou I'm a professor in the Department of
History and the program in American
Studies
I'm also the current head of college for
Timothy Dwight College as the head of
Timothy Dwight College I have the honor
of serving as the custodian of the
illustrious chub Fellowship established
in 1941 out of a prior large donation
for education purposes made in 1936 by
Hendon Chubb a graduate of the Yale
class of 1895 since its establishment
the Chubb fund has appeared to the goals
of providing encouragement and aid to
students interested in government and
American public affairs the fellowship
initially aimed to foster among Yale
undergraduates an interest in public
service in local and state affairs it
grew all over the years to include
numerous distinguished visitors in
national and international affairs as
well as leaders in the world of the arts
and humanities
since the 1940s the Chubb fellows
lecture series has inspired generations
of Yale undergraduates to undertake
public service and pursue leadership
roles in the hopes of creating a better
world today and for posterity the
fellowship has hosted four US presidents
George W Bush Gerald Ford Jimmy Carter
and Harry Truman in recent years we've
welcomed a wide range of national and
international leaders including
environmental activist bilk McKibben
Ambassador Samantha power physician and
humanitarian dr. hawa Abdi renowned
actor Shahrukh Khan an award-winning
songwriter and musician Paul Simon with
this quick description of the history
and aims of the Chubb fellowship I'm
delighted that we are welcoming to Yale
today the distinguished artist faith
Ringgold and as our spring 2018 Chubb
fellow
[Applause]
joining faith Ringgold today are members
of her family and staff her daughter
Michele Wallace is a scholar of African
American film and cultural studies and
she recently retired from City
University of New York after a lovely
career grace Mathews is faith pringles
assistant Kyle Mathews and Martha
Whitehead are part of faith Ringgold
anyone can fly Foundation and true core
volunteers
[Applause]
we're delighted that you were all able
to join us today born and raised in
depression-era Harlem New York City
Boardman brace in Depression era Harlem
New York City faith wrinkles career as
an artist educator writer and activist
spans more than half a century and as
you can see 60 years she earned a
bachelor's degree from City College of
the City University of New York in 1955
she then taught art in New York City's
public schools and worked on a master's
degree at City College which she
completed in 1959 in the 1960s as an art
teacher in the New York City Public
Schools she began a series of paintings
called American people that portrayed
the civil rights movement from a
feminist perspective the painting showed
ordinary people both black and white
confronting social barriers while
attempting to forge relationships in
their everyday lives
she also organized the fought for works
of african-american and women artists to
be included in museums and galleries she
demonstrated against the exclusion of
black and female artists by New York's
Whitney Museum of American Art and the
Museum of Modern Art from 1968 to 1970
1971 faith Ringgold co-founded where we
add a black women artists group in the
1980s she embarked on projects that
employed the medium of the story quilt
rooted in african-american communal
traditions of quilting and storytelling
that have been critical for connecting
families stories and lives across
generations works such as the 1988 tar
beach part one from the woman on bridge
series are currently in the Solomon R
Guggenheim museums permanent collection
and they make up some of her best know
masterpieces from this period faith
Ringgold has also produced numerous
public art projects included flying home
Harlem heroes and heroines for the
metropolitan transit authorities a
hundred and twenty-fifth Street subway
stop for the woman's house for the Rose
M singer Center on Rikers Island the
Crown Heights children's history quill
at public school 22 in Brooklyn New York
along with many others around the New
York City as well as around the country
since the 1990s she is also written and
illustrated many acclaimed children's
books such as tar Beach that was the
Caldecott on her book and winner of the
Coretta Scott King award she has helped
young readers explore African American
history through aunt Harriet's
Underground Railroad in the sky one of
my children's favorite books dinner at
aunt Connie's house on her civil rights
activist fannie lou hamer Mary McLeod
Bethune Zora Neale Hurston and many more
famous black women if a bus could talk
the story of Miss Rosa Parks won the
n-double-a-cp s Image Award in 2004
adults she has published her memoir in
1995 titled we flew over the bridge the
memoirs of faith Ringgold
she's professor emeritus at the
University of California San Diego where
she taught art from 1987 to 2002 she is
the recipient of more than 75 awards
including 22 honorary Doctor of Fine
Arts degrees she has received
fellowships and grants from the National
Endowment for the Arts John Simon
Guggenheim Memorial Foundation New York
foundation for the Arts and many more
for painting and sculpture and I'm now
delighted that she can add the Chubb
fellowship to her long list of
illustrious awards I'm also pleased to
say that the hopper windows commission
committee that is the hopper that
windows commissioned Kimmy for hopper
college here on Yale's campus and
several members of which are with us
today including head of college Julia
Adams
has recommended that faith Ringgold be
the artist to design new windows for the
hopper dining hall and again head of
college Julie Adams is here so this is
very exciting news and you are very much
the first audience the first public
audience to hear this announcement it's
been circulating sort of privately on
email this week so it's very exciting to
hear the announcement we're looking
forward to developing a conversation
with faiths over the coming months so
faith that chapter will be continued but
for today I'm delighted to celebrate her
life's work and her many achievements
and hear her talk anyone can fly so
please join me in welcoming faith
Ringgold to the podium good evening
thank you so much for inviting me and
for you coming this is a great honor I'm
so happy to be here this is one of my
favorite places back in the day when I
was going to college if you went to Yale
you were hot stuff especially in art
okay so thank you I'm here
all right in 1948 I made my first work
of art that I considered complete and
the finished work of art and is that not
am I not doing it correctly oh wait a
minute maybe that's the way no nothing's
moving what am I doing wrong
there you go back I want to go back go
back
just below oh oh there you go yes thank
you know they taught me at the City
College of New York I was told when I
was a young kid that when I graduated
from high school I was going to college
but I didn't know which college so we
walked down the street used to see these
boys rushing out of the subway at 140
Fifth Street and in Tacoma Avenue in
Harlem and going up the hill to convent
Avenue and down the street to the City
College of New York and I said mom why
can't I go to that where these boys
going she said they're going to City
College I said well why can't I go there
she said well you can however I didn't
know it was a boys school and so when I
went when I got to be eighteen in 1948
and went down to register at the City
College of New York that's when I found
out that I couldn't go there and I said
what were you talking about they said no
what do you want to do what do you want
to be I said be you know women didn't
work in those days be I I want to do all
right
they said what wait no you can't get a
liberal arts degree here because this is
a boys school so I just refused to hear
that because all my life I thought of
doing that however somebody at the
college said look she can do it she can
get a Bachelor of Arts in art education
and she can major in art and minor in
education and do her art and teach and
in a way that was great because my
family had a lot of teachers in it
they were too cool on the art now the
art was a little you know if he but the
teaching was fine and so I went to the
City College of New York and got a
bachelor's degree in art education and
then a master's in a Master of Arts in
art education and I am so glad that that
happened because I was able to teach
children and I hadn't planned to teach
anything I plan to do all but this way I
got a chance to find out how wonderful
the children are they are the best and
for those of you who teach them I'm sure
you know what had me their children
fabulous now in in 1948 I was 18 and I
was a freshman at the City College and
we were learning about all kinds of art
done in Europe like still life and and
so on and this was the first painting
that I really thought was good you know
because the teachers would tear
everything apart but um yeah so this was
this is my first oil on canvas and I
went on what does that mean a different
box well it's not happening what the
heck
okay nothing is happening here I need to
go on more than 60 years making and all
I'm getting is one piece I don't know
why it's not moving I'm pushing buttons
yeah oh okay go okay here in one of my
classes design oh we we had a fabulous
education at the City College in art and
I think they really did a wonderful job
on teaching us and one of the things
that we learned to do very well was to
create design I mean all kinds from
design aspects from all over all over
the world and so okay here we we got an
assignment to create a plain colored
acrylic on paper playing cards and most
of the kids in the class when we came
back and we went to show our homework
assignment they had created a whole deck
of cards I said women what are you doing
here this is it's not a you were not
supposed to make a deck of cards
supposed to do just one
and they said we do what we want and
that was there if it was very
competitive and of course the idea was
they're gonna make a deck of cards and
I'm gonna come in with my wand and you
know city college was free but not if
you only do gonna do one and everywhere
you go you're gonna be in trouble so I
said okay that's the way you all want to
do it huh and I learned from that don't
ever go in with Warren uh nothing make
sure when you get it name you can fill
up the whole board with your staff and
and I did yeah playing card 1948 in the
1960s I became a mature artist with the
American people series and black light
the 1960s was a time when things changed
in America and will never be the same
much was for the better however there
seems to be continuing longing for the
one step forward two steps backward that
has been a time-worn American legacy
since the 1600s I became a mature artist
okay let's move on okay
self-portrait I went into this whole
series of painting with stop signs and
circles and that was very prevalent in
those days pop art was what they was
saying it was and oil on stretched
canvas was my way of working and I am
cradling myself for the long haul ahead
of me
I was trying very hard to show my life
and to tell my story because to me that
is what an artist is supposed to be
doing telling the story on earth what's
going on
[Music]
art is important because you can tell
what happened to people all over the
world at any time in their history from
looking at their art and I wanted to be
a part of that I wanted to help to tell
the story of african-americans in
America at the time when I was vivid
when I was alive and I got that
opportunity to do that by becoming an
artist this is the American people
series and which was started in 1963 and
went on to 1967 this is actually an
image of my brother who died very early
in his life and I wanted to always
remember him he was such a sweetheart
but things were rough in those days and
he he could make it he didn't make it
my poor brother gone before his time I
think I need to go faster but I don't
know how to get that happening I became
an artist because I wanted to tell my
story as a black woman in America we
were in the height of the civil rights
movement and I wanted my art to be a
witness to the changes that were taking
place it was then that I announced my
arrival on the art scene as no longer
emerging I never liked that word
emerging
I was now a mature artist if not me who
if not now when
in 1967 I had my first solo show at the
spectrum gallery on 57th Street in New
York City and Here I am standing between
friends under the under actually this is
a across something linking women
together so that that there would be
some kind of mutuality between us and
not so much hate and destruction this is
the first painting in the American
People series I did in the summer a lot
of parties to raise during a lot of
parties to raise money for the civil
rights causes like the NAACP I was
staying with my daughters and my husband
in what Provincetown and it was very
interesting what was going on there the
people there were colorful and
interesting their images were
unforgettable I almost never forgot a
face they often show up in my paintings
yes I'm still looking and things are
getting more and more interesting for
members only we were trying to go to a
what are we trying to get to a park this
is a what the check mark a church school
picnic and these guys showed up to tell
us you know you're not supposed to be
here a lot of races a lot of prejudice
in different neighborhoods and so on and
so I got a chance to experience all
these things and to feel the power of
being an artist to record what I saw for
men
only well you had to be a member well I
couldn't be a member to all these things
and absolutely they wanted us to leave
we left have you ever had an experience
like that
well actually never happened to me again
but I did have that first one who told
us to get the hell out of it
neighbors a lot of racism in the schools
and in the neighborhoods and all with
people not wanting you to live next door
or whatever could you make a painting of
people who wouldn't want you to live
within would you want to a family of
people who want to keep it their way
these things have been difficult through
the years and I have tried to do what I
can't could have it click again the
civil rights triangle you know the
president of the NAACP back in those
days was not black whether you know that
or not but that's what these the
triangle is about and I was right in the
middle of it and in that place where we
went Martha's Vineyard where my mother
had a friend and I started these
paintings because they were very
important members of NAACP but there's a
lot going on and I wanted to record my
feelings about it watching and waiting
people had to you know wait their turns
to see if they could participate in what
is going who is the man at the door
standing there waiting for his chance to
to be heard to sit at the table so to
participate who was watching and waiting
what for okay this was mr. Charlie uh I
think the idea was is that he was a nice
guy
so come on red blue and white arrows
pointing downward suggested that things
were not gonna be all that great stop
signs and all and mr. Charlie mr.
Charlie
see this man's hand on his heart and his
smile red stop sign red blue and white
arrows pointing downwards is he sincere
I think generally he might have been but
mr. Charlie was big in 1964 okay
63 and here is a whole pile up of guys
with their hands over one of them saying
face why are these men piled up on top
of each other what does the position of
their hands tell us it's a way of
keeping you down
who's the man on top how will you stay
there that is an interesting question
that America continues to battle with
some people want to be on top and they
will do anything to stay there and it is
unfortunate that we have still so much
going on that prevents people from
prospering
getting together and and prospering the
American dream
all women wanna bring like that and you
know a guy to go with it yeah that's it
yes sorry how can you achieve it well we
find a way don't we yeah yes I think so
I just made a you know black white
whatever um study now oh that was
important a lot of young kids got into
various schools that had had previously
prohibited black children going there
they would get in there and then they
would forget about doing the work and
they would flunk out study now don't
forget this painting is a message to
students see the for caution signs huh
see the red arrow and yellow red and
black stop sign why should you study now
because if you don't you gonna get
thrown out and that's not going to be
pleasant for anybody three men on
offense trying to decide which way
should they go what should they do
should they do this
could you make a picture about what you
did have you ever sat on the fence
could you make a picture about what you
did look back on it the family playing
huh some parents wanted their schools
kept segregated they had a plan to keep
them segregated for the most part their
plan worked
could you make a picture of the kids
at your school schools are still quite
segregated and they do it through the
neighborhoods being segregated keep this
neighborhood segregated the schools can
do it
god Bless America this was my very first
flag painting I was trying to make a
picture that looked patriotic does she
look patriotic what is patriotism all
right yeah I wanted to do that portrait
of an American youth I think I already
showed this one uh stop the red stop
sign what does this mean who is this
young man he reminds me of my brother
where his life was sort of set up for
you two of these girls are my daughters
Barbara and Michelle who are the other
children well they're kids they went to
school with why are they hiding and from
whom are they hiding or are they just
simply playing I wanted to show them
plain trying to be friends trying to
avoid the racism that followed children
that follows continues to follow
children everywhere woman looking in a
mirror okay yeah see the watercolor
which the plants with the plants outside
and the moon what feeling through
peeking through the leaves this is a
beautiful night and she is a beautiful
woman can you paint a woman looking in
the mirror and who is she by the way she
yeah this was fun to do the artist and
his model there were a lot of artists
at that time who thought they had an
idea about what kind of people I should
pay
don't don't paint this don't paint that
I do what I want oh yeah and there was
imagery that they thought was perfect
and correct and imagery that they
thought was not and I thought I could do
what I want what do you think of this
ongoing debate now black or just
American it was a lot of discussion
about whether you should pay black
people or who are the black people well
I can decide and I can make what I want
and I did why is our flag bleeding yeah
the flag is bleeding why is it bleeding
it's bleeding because our Liberty our
damage to some extent our freedom is in
trouble it was so difficult painting
that blood and if you've never tried
painting blood try it
it really feels dangerous then it all of
a sudden in 1967 somebody yelled black
power oh my god everybody got very upset
what I mean black and power these two
don't go together yeah something's wrong
and you see here what do you see written
in the horizontal put your head on the
right what do you see alright that's the
power and the black power was something
that somebody yelled on who was it for
me
Stokely Carmichael yeah that was a very
big day when that happened what happened
here oh okay oh my god that's funny
oh yeah okay the black light series okay
no this is I've done what what's going
on well this is my computer so now and
this is the subway on 121 5th Street and
and this is this whole series the black
light series in which I wanted to change
my use of colors and then dye which was
the left of the American people series
was died huh which has is now in the
collection of the Museum of Modern Art
after fifty year I did it fifty years
ago and they now having because I loved
Picasso and here's Guernica and we used
to go there take my daughter's there and
we would look at Guernica and so on and
in my series of American people I
thought it would I wanted to do a
spontaneous street Brian because there
was so many they would happen just I
mean it spontaneously right it would
break out and you would be in the middle
of it you had to get the hell out the
way and blood would be in the street and
when you got home nobody would have seen
it on television and it wouldn't be in
the newspaper the next day they just act
like a do net amazing and so I thought
I'm gonna do a painting showing a
spontaneous street riot and it
was inspired by Guernica which I used to
look at him all the time because of riot
- I mean a painting and I tried to what
was it Chase Manhattan Bank David
Rockefeller Center boo to my studio to
buy my first one first painting from a
bank huh from Chinese and I showed them
those paintings that you just saw and
they just said oh my god we can't take
any more we have to go and okay so but I
knew that David Rockefeller was gonna
send him back
so go ahead so they went and when they
came back I showed them the blacklight
series what was that go but could you go
back one wait yeah there we go
and they they wanted to buy this and my
mother said okay listen
no no they're coming back they're gonna
buy something show him something they
can buy it's a thing think about it it's
a bank okay it's a bank you gotta you
know think about that and so I did and
they liked it and they said they call it
the American spectrum no I called it the
American spectrum they wanted to call it
what they had an idea
it's calling I was trying to show
America with all this different shades
of people and anyway they boy
that's the key now titles mean a lot in
art you know you gotta be very aware of
the fact that many people buy a painting
based on the title very interesting
I thought and for years I used to go to
the chase and right outside the
president's office would be that
painting by nineteen 667 we had reached
the black is beautiful black pride black
power segments of the civil rights
movement of the 1960s
I wanted to create art to show the black
is beautiful skin tones of black people
we black people had never been called
beautiful before but it was a raging
black is beautiful okay I'll go for it a
black image in a black background like a
white image in a white background is
invisible without tonal variations so my
paintings would be dog but not black I
had to add some small amount of white
pigment to my colors to give them
opacity then I could add the black
pigment to darken my colors this was
wonderful I love working this way it was
magic how dark colors looked black
against the white canvas but when placed
next to each other
dark dull colors were clearly visible
you could see them much better I was in
France with the results I created the
following twelve canvases which I call
black light black paintings of black
people and this one big black was the
first one yeah that is the presence of
all color white is the absence of color
and I worked with those ideas in my
color
for many years and I still do accept IJ
I stop work working in oil paint because
I was allergic you know yeah it's a lot
of artists got sick from using oil paint
and an acrylic paint became very
important and so I went on and on in
order to make the and create clearly
defined abstract shapes can you make a
face by using abstract shapes and flat
colors try it black light I called it
soul sister I can't think of a more
liberating time in my life than the
1960s it was then that I learned to wear
my hair natural oh that's when the
naturally no more hot combs in my hair
black is beautiful black pride and black
power
all in one gesture yeah everybody's got
to hear oh wow do worry about that
anymore what is it
you got five what excuse me five minutes
well let's see what you got mommy and
daddy let's move on
more black light mommy and daddy 1969
keep go who's who's got the thing
[Music]
okay Nick and his guy oh here can i push
that you can push right here this button
okay good I'll go for all right green
black art poster oh the black art poster
the Schomburg library got that because
it's a library at home and they didn't
own anything of that so I gave her there
and I was in there just recently looking
for it you know it's very difficult to
find that I gotta go back and find it
can you make a picture to express
yourself without name-calling okay
I don't know red [ __ ] white [ __ ] oh
there was a lot of [ __ ] yelling in
those days and I wanted to say it's not
appropriate unless you are a [ __ ]
don't say [ __ ]
okay you're one okay not one don't do it
the American spectrum okay this is the
one that the chase board flag for the
moon die [ __ ] I'm not sure who owns
that now somebody does you remember what
oh it is Oh silver Stan yeah all right
here we are
um u.s. America blind I just wanted to
do party time I wanted people dancing
the 1970s in the 787 these are
discovered my roots in African art and
began to paint and create are specific
to my identity as a black woman I made
dolls and and masks inspired by my
painting I began to write
Oh No I did this for the woman's house I
got singer singer center for the woman's
house yeah oil-on-canvas well the men
thought they didn't like it very much
when they moved in and the women moved
to the the woman's house and they
painted over it in white house paint
that was a problem yeah that's yeah that
wasn't nice they said they got tired of
listening looking at those [ __ ] okay
yeah so but but the I called the the the
head of the prison Center and he had
raised $25,000 and he had that painting
restored and now it you would never know
that it had been painted over with white
house paint and it is now going to be in
the collection of the Brooklyn Museum
not going back to the prison
no I yeah that was hard okay let's see
what's going on oh my god I have done so
many different kinds of all kinds of
painting and these are the tankers that
I discovered and these are my dolls
which I do actually discovered making
dolls and efforts and here is the
mosaics
hollom heroes then hell what go back
with oh go back where okay okay here yes
masks and dolls are really fun and I
loved making them I like I like to work
in different different media huh
we flew over the bridge remember oh I
wrote my memoir in 1980 had it published
and it was very difficult getting that
to happen and then the masks freedom of
speech commissioned by the Constitution
Center to celebrate the 200 anniversary
of the Bill of Rights and it is in the
collection of the museum Oh
the Metropolitan Museum of Art here's
the subway in Harlem yeah
so I've had a lot of opportunities to do
many things and the idea is when you get
an opportunity do it and don't turn down
any opportunities that's one thing
that's very important to learn as you're
in college don't decide that you
shouldn't do it yeah this is a hundred
and twenty-fifth Street and what Lenox
Avenue yeah
these series of of people four tricks 52
now
oh no the 52 mosaics was done for the
Civic Center in California that was fun
52 images huh yeah I wanted I wanted to
create imagery of people walking in the
subway all different kinds of people
dancing performing playing music
whatever playing different sports
yeah and I won that Commission mosaics
Commission in California so if you're
ever in LA go see it
52 images yeah make it mosaics is really
fun I painted images and mother did the
ko this is echoes of Hall in my first
quilt I and I started writing on my
second one who's afraid of untrim i'ma
see the story I wrote and I wrote that
story because I had written my
autobiography and could get it published
and I said I know it'll do I'll write on
my art and when they see the art they'll
read the story that I can do I mean I
will not allow somebody to decide what
my story is I will write it Sony's quilt
and on and on
woman on the bridge they said this is at
Crystal Bridges right now Museum of
American Art until Arkansas Here I am
with Oprah and and Maya Oprah
commissioned this painting for me to do
Maya that was really nice of her but she
she doesn't believe in having anybody
see the work fortunately for me
but some people buy a work of art and
they want to hide it from the world
after you know and that's not it's not
fair but it's at Crystal Bridges now the
museum and there I am in front of it and
that's good hey John yeah this work
won't on a bridge two or five double
dutch on the George Washington Bridge so
by the le roman half gallery and here is
dancing the loot the whole French
collection I went to to France on
several occasions and wanted to do a
tribute to the artists that I learned
about the American collection the French
collection so many artists that became
important in my life who I learned about
at school Denzel Washington a princess
cover and my books my children's books
very important and here are a collection
of them yeah the first offer I got was
to do to our Beach and a lot of people
said you know artists don't make
children's books and at City College
they never taught us illustration but
when I got an offer to create a book
with tar Beach I was taught don't turn
down any opportunities and I didn't and
it was my first book and now I've done
19 and I'm still going coming up with
more yeah and Here I am with my husband
he's in a nursing home now so keeps me a
little confused if any of you have
anybody in a nursing home you know
that's kind of difficult but without him
I wouldn't be standing here because I
wouldn't have been able to quit my job
teaching
huh no I would have had to continue
without a doubt coming to Jones Road
it's my great-great-grandmother Susie
Shannon she lived to be a hundred and
ten in there something but that is so
amazing I she always coming to Jones
Road part one when we moved to New
Jersey so that I could open a bigger
studio because as an artist you know you
you outgrow a studio you fill it up and
then you need another one bigger and so
then I moved to my neighbors thought I
was trying to open up a rooming house or
something I couldn't understand why they
thought that but didn't matter you know
they were gonna try to keep me from
moving in but I got in anyway so I did a
tribute to them coming to Jones Road we
just keep coming just keep sorry
under a blood red sky commissioned by
the Metropolitan Museum avoid huh yep
that's right and there's pretty
dedicated to you I had a dedicated to
him because without him we couldn't move
to Jones room because I couldn't afford
that yeah we're here on Emory got us now
come into Georgia world acrylic on
canvas a symbol of freedom to a couple
trying to get married they had to
secrete themselves in the woods
in order to to get married in those days
during slavery escape to freedom Harriet
Tubman I went to give tribute to some of
these women who were so heroic during
those days Nott luther king wonderful
framed in a tub mother made this danke
for me and I didn't have a painting
ready for it and she said oh that
doesn't matter it doesn't need a
painting you could just hang who talked
about that she was too much oh she's too
much
mama can sing Papa can blow every all
artists did jazz pictures of some kind
and I hadn't done any until 2000
something I had made a jazz picture yeah
something like that right yeah and it's
really very popular for it is to create
jazz pictures somebody stole my broken
heart and now I'm making lots of cool
and a letter from Martin Luther King
while confined here in Birmingham City
Jail he was told you know why are you
coming here causing trouble that's why
you're in jail so he did that series of
letters and I got asked to illustrate
them and I did that was a great fun and
it turned out to be I think eight books
by a print a work show the right to vote
yeah work counties without a single
Negro registered to vote you look back
on these times Oh police brutality view
through stained-glass windows
who worships here who is their God
Martin Luther King this this is the
subjects that he sent to this Minister
who said why are you here causing
trouble that's why you're in jail and he
said I'm here and he expressed some of
the things that had happened in America
that made him get arrested police
brutality view through stained glass
windows for more than two centuries are
for parents labored in this country
without wages and here is the bus
boycott now this one here probably it's
very it's the Declaration of
Independence because it was created
interesting at a time when it was still
slavery in America and so I did this
series of paintings I have born 13
children and seen most all sold off to
slavery and when I cried out with my
mother's grief none but Jesus heard me
and he when they said all men are
created equal
I added and women and I had a woman
speech presented by Sojourner Truth in
1851 in Akron Ohio this was so fun to do
and there was a painting you know okay
yeah this this was a very wonderful
experience doing the absolute Tyranny
understanding this what could I say also
absolute Tyranny what was going on a lot
with the people hanging from the trees
taxes on us oh we have appealed to their
native justice and magnanimity favorite
Douglass
I was brought up to understand that in
America my freedom was not more than a
promise that would be a struggle and
could be in many instances denied these
are all things I really wanted to do yes
we can and we did yeah it's too bad we
couldn't have our first woman president
maybe wouldn't have so many problems
like we have today but what can I say
somebody didn't do it I did I went
boating for now I did I'm sorry I voted
for her I voted for him I vote for her
unfortunately yes indeed now this is a
sculptor who did this at some Museum and
asked different people to paint the
sculpture and I painted these of Obama
I'm wondering you know just has he ever
seen this well you don't know I don't
know yet flag stories now the flag
stories I did because I woke up one
morning and and and and they were planes
flying into these buildings and I
thought it was some kind of
advertisement but it wasn't it was it
was 9/11 when Tuesday morning we faced
the devil in the sky and told him that
freedom will never die and I just I
couldn't believe I was seeing what I was
seeing and I just kept doing these flags
because I
I was just overwhelmed oh my goodness I
couldn't believe it my darling we are
facing the devil in the sky a hateful
man with a what a terrible plan that all
of us shall die oh my this was such a
frightening morning on Tuesday morning
you called me from the burning sky
you're searing words of pain will
forever remain encrusted in my heart my
darling we are facing the devil in the
sky a hateful man with a hellish plan
for all of us to die there is a mountain
in every Valley but is there a safe
haven in the sky if so we will try if
not my darling I love you goodbye that
was a horrible morning when these people
were dying when these planes and oh my
god a lie Tuesday morning 911 that never
happens again
I just kept making flags I didn't know
what else to do well 9/11 suicide
bombers in heaven we think not heavens
not where they're at there's been a huge
mistake but for heaven's sake what's a
little sin we will get you in and we can
double date I'm in hell yeah the idea of
that whole thing was just cuckoo freedom
flag
so you're the 19 men we've been waiting
for well I'm the devil and here's what
Hell has in store 90 [ __ ] on a bed of
coals and a million hags with tortured
souls serial killers assassins rapists
murderers and more with an eternity of
time for you to enjoy and enjoy and
that's what happened on 9/11 when 19
suicide bombers went to help oh yeah
this was oh this was such a day this is
too much they just couldn't stop I I
couldn't believe it and then after I
began to believe it I couldn't stop stop
doing it and I made this series for the
ACLU of posters channel 13 and okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we could have some questions now good
okay
hi thank you so much that was just
wonderful I spoke to you earlier I've
been an art educator for years and every
child who ever sees your work celebrates
it and loves it and the messages are so
fantastic I just wondered if there was
ever a subject that you would like to
cover that you've never painted I can't
think of one at this point because I'm
87 so there used to be some but not
anymore
no I got a chance and I've done it
everything I want to do I'm working on
my game quilted ook oh and if you know
Sudoku how many people know Sudoku
well quilted ook oh is a lot like it you
just go on iTunes and what's the other
Google Play and type in quilt to do Co
qu IL t you do you K oh and you play my
game it's so fun because with Sudoku
when you get finished the only thing
you've got are 81 numbers and you throw
that paper out but with quilt to do Co
you've got a poster you can put on the
wall ok
it's gonna be fun what's your favorite
thing about art I like the power of
creativity that I am able to create
something out of my own imagination that
has never been done before by me that's
what I like about it it's it gives you a
feeling of power that is very memorable
I love creating art and I love my on
yeah I do I love it I don't try to
please other people with my art I'm
happy when they are pleased but as an
artist I think it's important that you
love what you're doing you love it
because you have no idea what other
people want ok
thank you for the pleasure an afternoon
of beautiful beautiful work thank you
well I want to ask a very serious
question at this time okay because as a
as a nation we are in deep deep trouble
and I wonder if you think that replacing
the arts in the curriculum will help
reduce school shootings rework replacing
the art in the curriculum between art
back Oh putting art back intends yeah
that's interesting
I'm wondering if children are losing
their sensibility there what do you
think that's the reason why they're
shooting each other and their love for
themselves and love yes for Humanity for
the world for creativity for yeah I
don't know is is the art out of the
schools completely at this point it's
coming out it's going down though right
unfortunately you know children have
have such an ability to create art with
me little and to be denied that
opportunity is sinful so that if they
don't get it in school as parents you
have to make sure they get it at home
because it's in them I know they're not
getting the music either huh they're not
getting the music they are getting the
music okay okay
well what can I say
that's unfortunate if they are being
denied the ability to be created and to
tell their story I wasn't going to speak
but I'm very compelled right now I'm an
art teacher and I'm a survivor of the
Sandy Hook school shooting and five
years ago I got to meet faith Ringgold
and she validated so much of what I had
experienced and I came to her because it
was tar Beach that allowed my students
to fly above the pain and the horror and
I can't say enough about how you have
influenced to this day you are
influencing children's idea of what it
is to create in to be and to fly and I
can't thank you enough for that
[Applause]
if anyone can fly all you got to do is
try right thank you very much for
telling me that
yeah so I guess as someone who now for a
very long time has not only been a part
of but shaped conversations on race and
gender and belonging I think a couple of
people have commented on the fact that
in certainly in America but I think the
the world in general it has I mean you
know they've never had its way to begin
with but is certainly more wayward than
it's been in a while and I'm wondering
what you have to share about being in
the center of that conversation for a
world which doesn't want to be having it
right now well you just have to be
forceful and find ways that are unique
to you to bring love and truth into the
world and especially to the children
they have a right to embrace the world
as children they need to to have the
world open to them to have opportunity
to learn and without it oh my god that
is so awful I can't imagine how it must
be to not be able to see the world as so
many of us have taken for granted
because as you get older you're going to
become more and more aware of what you
have missed let's hope it doesn't
continue
but we have to do something about it and
I would think that one thing we could do
is get rid of what's going on at the
White House yeah I mean the children
can't do that somebody's got to do it
and you know how unfortunate I mean I
just think about how I would feel if I
if there's a child I had had somebody in
the White House like that must be home
just think about it so we can change it
though if we get together we can do it I
think so do you agree yes
yeah so I would liked to once more thank
the wonderful faith Ringgold
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you there's a lovely reception
that is gonna be outside in the you AG
lobby please feel free to join us it is
open to all of you your one your been a
wonderful audience and this is our way
of thanking you thank you thank you